[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday July 31st
today's video comes in six distinct
parts that's a lot of parts so let's get
right to it
part one harry potter hank apparently
today's Harry Potter's birthday which is
a great excuse for me to set up one of
the champagne poppers that I got for
free when I was getting the green
hairspray they were having a very
eccentric sale at the party store the
sale was if you buy an item we will give
you champagne poppers Oh happy birthday
Harry also on the topic of Harry Potter
Hank I would like to suggest that if you
ever happen to start a wizard rock band
that you definitely should call the
wizard rock band
Tonks for the memories that joke is
courtesy of our secret sister Maureen
and speaking of secret siblings part two
secret siblings
Hank way back on February 21st of this
year our secret brother Tom made a
strange and obscure prophecy he said I
believe there are more secret siblings
now obviously since Tom our secret
sister Maureen has emerged but I'm
wondering Hank are there more Hank as we
begin to get more video responses I'm
starting to think that maybe there are
more secret siblings secret siblings who
will take up the oppressive yoke of
vlogging and periodically respond to our
videos nothing against you but I always
wanted a big family anyway Hank I
wouldn't be surprised if some
nerdfighters started being our secret
siblings nerdfighters can do anything
look that can't even spell nerdfighters
with pretzels part three Reading Rainbow
Hank I've recently been reading two very
good in very different books first we
have my kosher bonds 411 page novel the
Yiddish policeman's Union now if the
world were full of Michael Chabon geeks
instead of being full of Harry Potter
geeks everyone would be like no you say
shaven no you say it Siobhan
no you say it sha'ban anyway Hank this
is a great book but as an added bonus
it's very similar to the color of my
wall secondly we have Eileen Cooper's 32
page book the golden rule it's like the
cutest book ever written about the
golden rule as an added bonus both of
those books adhere to be in your pants
rule I mean the Yiddish policeman's
Union in your pants
what kind of Union are they have it in
there and the golden rule in your pants
I mean obviously do unto others pants as
you would have them do unto your pants
part for Reading Rainbow Redux
Hank for the first time I'm about to
read the finished copy of a book called
an abundance of katherines which was
written by me I have to read this book
for a top-secret reason that I can't
even tell you but it means that I have
to break for the first time my
unbreakable vow never
forever-ever-ever to read books that
i've written once they're published
since it was published I've never read
Looking for Alaska except read little
snippets at bookstores there are two
main reasons why I don't like rereading
my books
first I already read them a bunch of
times before I published them second
once they're published there's no way
that I can change them and so everything
that I discovered that I dislike is like
horribly painful but I absolutely have
to reread Catherine's now so I'm trying
I'll let you know if I still like it
part five songs hey I don't know what
your song is gonna be about tomorrow but
I do know one thing someday somewhere
you must write the song that was
suggested by nerdfighter Nate jungle
pants Nate jogger pants suggested that
you write a 1960s style protest song
that's about why ninjas and pirates need
to put away their mutual hatred for each
other to bring about world peace hey I
think this is a great idea because
someone has got to do something about
the endless cycle of recrimination and
violence that goes on between ninjas and
pirates I mean heck ninjas and pirates
are like the sunnis and shias of
hypothetical reality I mean I would
write the song myself except I don't
think I do a very good job um it could
be like all we are saying is give ninja
pirate peace a chance yeah I think you
can do better than that part six the
outro Hank I'll see you tomorrow PS
you're back on the odd days